[Music]
every way i slice it
if i go after your sister alone
one of us comes back in a box
i can do this myself
no one else needs to get hurt
i'm glad it's you
had to be
in cooperation with netflix ryde
launched the first league of legends
animated series on the streaming
platform in november of course we are
talking about arcane there is no need to
double check whether the entire project
was a success after all the series won
the hearts of all viewers after the
first three episodes alone and swept
other movies and series from the top
spot across countries now all the
episodes are out and the finale came as
a bombshell the nine episodes are packed
with all sorts of easter eggs and
surprises leaving plenty of room for fan
theories and who would have guessed
season 2 was confirmed promptly this is
why we have compiled the most important
information for you in this video and
provide a small preview of possible
storylines in the second season needless
to say there is a huge threat of
spoilers for all episodes
if you want to watch the series first
you should marathon it now and then come
back here as soon as you are done
if you haven't watched the series yet no
worries we will briefly explain what
arcane is all about in the progressive
city of peldova there are two facets the
shining upper city where science rules
and masterminds like the founder
heimerdinge live and the lowest city of
zone in which a spark of life barely
reaches the impoverished alleys and
where the siblings of v and powder are
raised by the former radical vendor
while the latter grew up in poverty the
inventors jason victor resided in the
upper city with the help of magic stones
they developed the new technology the
so-called hextech however the two worlds
collide when vander is murdered by his
former friend silko the ladder plus the
straits of sound using the mystery's
drug shimmer and thus comes to power
after vander's death both sisters are
separated by the calamity and while one
attempts to prevent an outright battle
between the upper and lower cities the
other consumed pyolasis works straight
toward it in order to avert disaster
after all one sister received support
from the enforcer caitlyn and ekko with
whom she grew up in the slums of zom yet
jayce victor and their hextech will
influence the future of the city in
various ways as well without them
knowing it this is all we're willing to
reveal here so you will have to watch
the series for yourselves you can
believe us when we say that it is worth
it
how does arcane manage to excite the
viewers that much the first thing to
mention is the animation style which has
rarely been seen before the setting
looks perfect in every detail and the
stylistic differences between the two
districts are spot on while pildera
sparkles and flashing steampunk fashion
everything in zionist greenish brown and
musty equally differently animated of
the city's people while the gangsters
and sly characters of zound look rather
gruff and mark with thick lines the
elite from the other city can hardly be
surpassed in terms of subtlety and
filigree this is animation and design at
its best precisely this kind of art is
also reflected in the plot it quickly
becomes clear that arcane is not for
children the gloomy approach of the
series and the development of the
characters have no equal the
disintegration of the personality of
individual characters almost brings
tears to your eyes and you can't help
but root for them particularly well done
here is the split into three episodes
each one could almost think there were
three small seasons that were released
in a single month each block contains a
completed storyline and a new plot
however something that probably amazed
most of the gamers is that you really
don't need any prior league of legends
knowledge to love and understand the
series each character starts from
scratch and despite a mere six hours of
running time the development of each
character occurs at just the right pace
first we will discuss the biggest and
actually already proven theory which is
that vendor will become warwick in the
future this is already hinted at in the
first episodes vendor is referred to as
the hound of the underground which is a
reference to warwick who will be roaming
the streets of zone actually the best
way to prove this theory is with the
champion lore as most players know
warwick was created by the cam tag
scientist singh who is silko's doctor
this can be seen in part 2 at the latest
when the accent with the shimmer makes
him bandage his face just like the
champion from league of legends at the
end of the last part a brief shot shows
warwick hanging from the ceiling of
saints left before his completion if you
refuse to believe there was warwick
there is even official artwork from rye
that looks just like this scene for
other evidence in league of legends
there are certain voice lines when
champions meet in the rift when warwick
and vi do so the wolf says who taught
you how to punch which is a genius
reference considering he himself taught
it to her as a child if you stall down
the brilliance of the series creators
then brace yourself because when circle
tells bander in episode 2 i'll show you
what you really are warwick's music is
playing in the background
let us move on to the second theory the
fact that mel has her origins in noxus
cannot only be seen in the last episodes
but already in act 2 when she draws a
picture of the mortal bastion the
capital of noxus
right after that there are first posts
on reddit stating that mel belongs to
the notorious black rose a secret
society in runeterra that tries to
infiltrate all governments and pull the
strings on the entire planet the head of
this organization is le blanc now in the
last episodes we learn a bit more about
mel's past and from the way she's
presented the theory seems rather
unlikely but not inconceivable as we
discover medara is one of the ruling
houses of noxus the events therefore
occur before the unification of noxus by
darius and swain thus mal could have
been taken in and supported by the black
rose as an exile of her family in order
to climb up the ladder of pill tower
quickly however there are further
eastern accent theories about mel for
instance just be
jing's super mega death rocket smashes
into pilton's council chamber you can
see her armor light up and that despite
the fact that she has no significant
abilities this may also have teased her
as the new champion for the computer
game at this start of episode 8 where
she has to decide whether the girl shall
live or die a realm is introduced as
well which we might to get to see in
season 2 namely that of ionia we can
tell this from the girl's clothes as
well as from her necklace
one of the nicest easter eggs for fans
are certainly the various abilities that
we get to see at the end for example
when vay and jay is rushing to the
shimmer factory we see his shot blast
his hyper shield and his thundering blow
but we also get to see vi's passive her
blast shield as he fights sevico silco's
number two whether the blue c deals are
meant to represent the relentless force
we can only guess but not really tell
because let's face it all of her punches
were fierce but the greatest of all
easter eggs in this regard was probably
the last scene though when jinx
completes their fishbone with the arcane
crystal and sends her ultimate at
peltier's council with the super mega
death rocket thus she really was the
very first to figuratively reach level
six
the first time heimerdinger sees jason
victor's hex crystal he seems to
remember a terrible event a great
calamity and in the center a person
being burned alive
this might be an allusion to the rune
wars that plagued gruntera more than 900
years ago and through which the planet
and the realms were formed there the
world ruins were used to wage a global
war as a result the plan was almost
wiped out had the celestials and rise
not intervened yordles were also around
at the time we know about poppy for
example also their room is that in
battle city the whole of the yordle's
time passes differently than in the rest
of the world so heimerdinger could be
much older than his 307 years in the
first act of the series
only a few would have noticed it but
there were already clear indications in
the first act that twitch was already
born mantis the red which was presented
to silico by singh for experimental
purposes and was given shimmer after
that it mutated killing the cat in his
cage in the most brutal way what makes
us think that this is twitch well once
you take a closer look at twitch's
splash art you can see the same thing
glow in his eyes as caused by the
shimmer besides that's also the best
explanation as to how we managed to
mutate in addition we know by now that
singh doesn't give up on any of his test
objects but artificially keeps them
alive in order to learn from them the
same is already done with the dragon
like creature in episode 6 which by the
way is nothing more than a full grown
form of real little legend from team
fight tactics we can generally assume
that zing will play an increasingly
important role in the rest of the story
we could fill another 10 episodes just
with easter eggs and theories in benzo's
story in episode 1 alone we already
spotted ruby and sapphire crystal
outside the door in the room is
tryndamere's helmet our abandons death
cap and many may not know it anymore but
in his hand he holds a heart of gold the
support item used to bring 5 gold every
10 seconds in season 3.
finally we would like to focus on
something really important namely how
this series might progress after all we
know one thing for sure it will
definitely continue as ryan told us in a
teaser shortly after the season finale
first and foremost it will be
interesting to see who actually survived
jinx super mega death rocket there are
not going to be many we are pretty sure
about jace but not about anyone else so
we can assume that in any case there
will be civil war between polter and
zound which will end in zound's
independence it will also be exciting to
observe the influence that noxus will
have due to the presence of mel's mother
in pill tower she has already willingly
indicated her support for the city of
progress likewise interesting will be
victor's development who for the most
part still possesses his human body and
is thus close to death ekko is also only
at the beginning of his journey with the
support of heimerdinger he could manage
to use the hashtag for his technique to
get closer to his ultimate ability which
is the manipulation of time again time
jump would be conceivable in lore
caitlyn and avaya both already trained
in forces with kade even being the
sheriff of billtower so bender's
transformation to warwick could also be
accomplished and the two would have to
hunt down vice actual foster father
something we can also very well imagine
is that there will be more locations
that is noxus and ionia indeed this was
hinted at in the beginning of episode 6
and mel's mother also spoke of a
powerful enemy in noxus
so
perhaps we could see the beginnings of
the invasion of noxus on the peaceful
land and thus the first champions of the
empire
in addition to the champions already
introduced in season 1 it is very likely
that we will finally get to see warwick
in season 2 as mentioned before orianna
was teased as well in case you didn't
notice she was the woman in sings pocket
watch and the season finale if we assume
that victor completes his transformation
this also opens up space for many more
heroes like blitzcrank dr mundo and zack
also a possible candidate would be
camille the enforcer could battle
alongside caitlyn for the spotted
sheriff and try to fill the power vacuum
at the top
however the plan is now to continue with
arcane only as already communicated in
an interview in the la times ride and
high when they say aiming high they are
not talking about another series but
about hollywood the mcu serves as a
great model for this in other words they
want a rune terror cinematic universe
and let's face it this is not
unthinkable if we shift the setting to
ionia and noxus then we can't help but
call demacia into play at some point and
by then the whole concept will have
reached a magnitude of possible
storylines that could fall vast number
of series and films basically arcane has
shown a new what made right great they
did not reinvent the wheel rather they
analyzed the best features of the
opposition and combined them into one
product for that reason alone we have
high hopes for their work and are
already looking forward to what is to
come in the future however for the time
being the second season of arcane won't
be available on netflix until 2023 this
is of course hard to accept but good
things come to those who wait
we could and would like to go on
philosophizing and analyzing for hours
but we want there to be room for your
creativity what theories do you have in
mind from season 1 and which characters
do you really want to see featured in
season 2 make sure to let us know in the
comments below and if you like this
video give us a thumbs up we really
appreciate it see you next time
[Music]
you